a brutal reminder that peace in Northern
Ireland cannot be taken for granted
police tape cordons off the scene of
Wednesday night's attack a sports pitch
where an off-duty police officer had
finished coaching a youth team when two
gunmen shot him four times
condemnation came quickly from across
the political Spectrum this is an
absolutely shameful and grotesque attack
on a police officer here at this very
busy Sport and recreational Hub this
evening I can say tonight that words of
condemnation are strong enough to
condemn what has actually happened here
tonight the scars in this town in Omaha
are raw and Sewer from 25 years and
Beyond it of violence
film and the victims and the families
that have suffered that Ronan care who
was killed during his jury as a police
officer and now we have a police officer
in this community again tonight targeted
a planned attack
he was fighting for his life in the
hospital
Omar saw the deadliest and last major
bombing of Northern Ireland's so-called
troubles 29 people died when an IRA
Splinter Group detonated a car bomb in
1998 just four months after the signing
of the Good Friday peace agreement
police say their primary focus for this
shooting is the new Ira a group of
dissident Republicans who want a United
Ireland they've launched an attempted
murder investigation I would also like
to confirm that in this fast-paced
investigation this morning we have
arrested three men aged 38 45 and 47 in
Oma and coal Island
in connection with John's attempted
murder
they're currently been questioned by
detectives at Musgrave serious crime
Suite events like this are rare and
police say they're keeping an open mind
as to motives but northern Ireland's
troubled history doesn't always stay in
the past Rory challenge Al Jazeera